make way for the Hall of Famer Hallie
long joining us from Montana I don't
think you have a speed limit up there do
you Howie in Montana yeah they actually
do years ago they didn't think back the
callee I don't know how many years ago
was now we shot Broken Arrow in
Lewistown Montana and that was about
probably about eight hours from where we
are in the northwest corner and there
was no speed limit had a rental car and
unbeknownst to me rental cars have a
governor at about 95 miles an hour's no
but I mean you're driving in Montana and
there's nothing for you know hours and
there was no speed limit but since that
time they've they've implemented a speed
limit and you're you're are you on the
deck of your your home there on the lake
yeah I'm looking at the mission
mountains and cross could do Bay right
now and it's beautiful
so we sent kids here all's good who is
the second most famous person in your
neighborhood golly well Todd heaps down
a little bit
Phil Jackson's on over and big arm yeah
a lot of people are up and we're on
Flathead Lake Flathead Lake is bigger
than Lake Tahoe it's 28 miles long 15
miles wide the bougie lake is whitefish
no that's where the resort is and you
know it's kind of overrun I mean I can
take my hands off the steering wheel on
my boat and not hit anybody on the fifth
of July so it's real nice if Hard Knocks
was around when you were with the
Raiders no what would we have seen it'll
be good hard bed I'll bend a good hard
dock no I listen there was a different
time it was certainly a different time
and a different organization you know
the things that happen you know and you
never write that you never write that
book
it was a fascinating time you go from
going over where there's a priest on
every floor the Oakland Raider locker
room
you know John Minh to zag and had
Hendrix not knowing and you know Jim
Plunkett arch shel Gene Upshaw cliff
branch you know it was a remarkable
place to to be and no one really got
into the complex I mean we never had
people at our practices and there were
certainly was no media and there weren't
a lot of you know what you would call X
it's kind of like going ringing when you
go to when you go into an linen bill is
kind enough to invite you into practice
you're standing on the sidelines by
yourself because there there's no one
else in the building you know and and
there are no distractions it's all about
one thing and that's what it was that
and certainly you don't have much of a
choice I mean they paid 320 million
dollars in relocation fees they've
played three game three years in a row
they played a game a home game overseas
so I you know at what point with all
that's going on there with all the
turnover you've got a new GM you've got
a slew of new players you're in your
final year in Oakland I understand it's
a good story and and John is a very
entertaining guy so I'm sure it will
make for good television and but I think
at the end of the day I think the most
important thing is winning football
games and I think John and mike Mayock
certainly feel that way we had Chris
Simms on we've had a couple of people on
recently who say Erin Donald is the best
interior defensive lineman in history
yeah he get there who would be his
competition because I'd still like to
put Mean Joe green up against anybody
totally different time though Dan it's
kind of like it's somewhat like
comparing well everything's bigger
stronger faster yes okay
that Steelers offensive line averaged
252 pounds across the board 260 maybe
today's off largest offensive line
average 322 help Mike Kyle 6 7 330
everything is bigger stronger faster the
guy that played Joe's position is 330
340 now so the game is bigger stronger
faster Terry would throw time you'd have
to check this but there were some
playoff games we throw 22 passes you
know that feels like that's on the high
end to it that's on the high end so how
do you compare it's impossible to
compare errors Aaron Donald me is you
know you're talking about interior
defensive linemen I'm saying he's in the
conversation for the best football
player in the NFL right now okay but do
you think Brady is the best quarterback
of all time
you know once again what's the situation
for example Joe Montana San Francisco
for Super Bowls undefeated in Super
Bowls what's the criteria that that
offense that team was innovative it was
surgical you watch what New England did
what they did in the Super Bowl what
they did in Kansas City you know they
went back to they can morph into it's
it's game to game quarter quarter have
to have seriously series they can change
who they are and they do it every year
and the team you see in weeks one
through five doesn't look like the team
you see in week seven through twelve and
then certainly into the playoffs but do
you think he's the best quarterback how
about this you have a one game to win
thank you I think based on what the
criteria is winning Super Bowls I think
you have to say that okay but you have
one game to win and you can't take any
of your former quarterbacks
all right who you taking one game to win
uh who's the coach John Madden's the
coach well then you got a pretty good
shot with a with a bunch of quarterbacks
I think John was an innovative guy on
that team with certainly in that offense
was innovative and you know we just lost
we lost a great Raider and in my mind a
hall-of-famer and it's a shame that he
didn't get the call yeah and I hope that
next year halli because if we're gonna
put in 20 new players with a hundred
anniversary and I mentioned I think Zach
Thomas is a hall-of-famer
I think cliff branches a hall-of-famer
Allen Faneca is a hall-of-famer Steve
Hutchinson's a hall-of-famer back and
look up the number of AFC championship
games Super Bowls and numbers for
example when cliff Branch I think came
out of college and I was listening to
him I was driving down the road in my
truck and I heard him on NFL radio when
he was at Colorado I think he got 12
ball to senior year you know how
different is the college game how
different is the pro game I know one
thing and it's kind of the litmus test
for great players when you get on Monday
and you're or Sunday night whenever it
is that you're you're putting together
your game plan and who's the guy
you have to stop yeah when they break
the hole yeah and how much of an
adjustment you have to make defensively
to compensate for who might be one of
the four fastest people on the planet
and was that until he was golly I think
when he was 62 you brought four or five
why mention him and Bob Hayes were the
first two guys they Bates they were
different they stretched the defense and
you had a throw deep passing mentality
and I love Freddy blitek off but you
know cliff branch was eight he was the
guy you had to worry more about than
Freddy blitek off in my opinion and
Freddy's a Hall of Famer well they're
different players yes
two different positions it's like
comparing a1 to a2 in basketball or
about you know for 205 you know it just
can't make that comparison it's you're
comparing for example you're you're
judging defensive linemen let's go
Richard Seymour New England Richard
Seymour played in the defense that it's
a selfless defense it goes from a three
for two or for three it's a two gap in
most situations you're playing the run
the defense is not about you it's not
about getting you in position to make
great plays it's getting the defense to
do what's called for to win the football
game
if Richard Seymour plays in a scheme
that's more pin your ears back and
attack he's got 105 sacks he how do you
judge a player you have to judge a
player by the scheme but do you think
rip or is it a two gap defense is is he
as hall-of-famer I think he is yeah I
know and I think that's gonna happen
soon enough I mean tie law great player
yeah
great player it's time that I think
you're gonna start to see some of those
players and I wrote down you talk about
Tom Brady
all the great quarterbacks are talked
about they were always partnered with a
pretty consistent cast of players I went
back and looked at and I forget the
numbers and I can get it to you you look
at the number of office the number of
tight ends the number of wide receivers
the number of running backs the number
of coordinators that Tom Brady's had
during this run I started with that win
over the Rams in the Super Bowl it's
amazing yeah interchangeable parts yep
yeah if you were a free agent money was
going to be the same where would you
want to play right now or in your prime
I can imagine playing anywhere else tan
okay let's take Oakland out of it well I
tell ya I've grown to really like
Chicago a lot great city that love
football you were in there and golly
it's it's special you think back to that
85 Bears came and particularly in that
defense you know which you're guaranteed
uh you know in that Buddy Ryan scheme
you're guaranteed at least a single
block didn't they knock out all your
quarterbacks and Ray guy was warming up
they piss ray guy was warm enough and
I'm not sure he was real committed to it
right on with a little bit guys was
coming on block knowing how to block
that defense you know that's a bear
front know know how to block see I
always think this steal Kurt and that's
the best defense I ever saw but there
was doomsday the Vikings were great you
guys were great the Bears were
unbelievable that year the Ravens the
Ravens maybe you know that was over
spread over a few years best defense
ever can you come up with an answer for
that period of time okay they did in
their period yeah I'd say the Steelers I
think they won four in six years yeah
and we were dominant intimidating and
you know when you look at the Bears look
at us III think you know and I'm not
comparing our defense to the Bears
defense I think our defense for that for
that to three-year stretch was really
good and certainly the performance in
the Super Bowl people forget that 83
Washington team had set a scoring record
damn good until the Chris Carter
Minnesota Vikings yeah they were I'm
watching them on film I remember like
yesterday I'm watching them I'm feeling
I'm going oh my god people are running
through holes that are big enough to
drive a truck through and they're just
picking people apart we've got our two
corners that you know they didn't really
need to get in the hollow
you know we had two three coverages
that's it we ran one blitz a game and
the one blitz we ran was a jet rip blue
slash off the left side backed up on
second and long
Jill Washington on a screen pass they
had killed us on it earlier in the year
up in Washington and what was a a
dynamic game for both teams offensively
even that Marcus Allen the number of
players were injured but we replaced
Matt Millen with Jack Squire ik-hee
spies Jill Washington the rest is
history
all right but but but for that Bears
team and for our team not winning the
second game second title or the third is
the thing that I think would be
disappointing for both teams it's great
to visit with you there in the off
season and hope to catch up with you
during the regular season it's always my
best to the family
Thank You Howie that's how a lone
Raiders Hall of Famer for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV streamed for free
on BR Live or download the Dan Patrick
show at
[Music]